hey guys it's justine and i wanted to
give you guys a little health update
video thank you
so much for all of your well wishes to
everyone who left comments to my friends
and family who have sent me gifts and
all kinds of things to my house to
brands who have reached out and also
sent things like it has been
incredibly overwhelming but the amount
of love and support that i have felt
from the audience and pretty much
everyone that i know has been
so incredibly just
i don't even know what to say like i've
been just speechless it was definitely a
really tough time because this is
something that happened so unexpectedly
and i'm incredibly active and healthy
and just kind of makes you really stop
and realize that anything can happen at
any time so if you missed the video
where i talked about the little health
scare that i had long story short
because the video is very long it's
actually about 17 minutes but it does
take you kind of through the whole
process of what happened but i ended up
the blood clot in my shoulder now since
that video came out i do have a few more
answers not really that many more but
what was incredibly helpful is hearing
stories from you guys it's so terrible
though that this is like something that
is so common
and people don't even know the signs or
the symptoms and i was very blown away
by how many other people who have been
affected by this not only you guys that
have been affected personally having it
happen to you but your family members
your friends people that you've lost
because of a blood clot and it seems so
trivial like you don't actually realize
how
severe this is until unfortunately it's
too late and that's when the severity of
the issue kind of comes up so now i just
want everyone to know the signs the
symptoms i even had an incredible call
with the national blood clot alliance
which i didn't even know that was a
thing until i started googling and
finding out that there's really not that
many resources but they have so many
incredible comprehensive resources
things to look for and i'll put a link
in the description if you want to check
that out to get more information because
it has been very helpful for me and i
think now just knowing that there's a
place that i can go to have these
resources and if you want more
information that there's just kind of
like a one-stop blood clot shop for you
to go to and i know i've kind of been
making light of the whole situation
because that's kind of how i deal with
things with humor and even the whole
time at the hospital i was just trying
to make jokes and keep my mind off of
what was going on but since then we have
some updates but where i kind of left
off was the actual diagnosis of what i
have is called thoracic outlet syndrome
in this kind of syndrome there's various
different degrees of it there's a bunch
of things that kind of fall under that
umbrella so the one that i have is kind
of the vein
type thoracic outlet syndrome where
there's not actually enough space in my
shoulder for the blood to flow to my arm
and this happens to a lot of athletes to
a lot of younger people who are very i
guess doing a lot of repetitive motions
like swimming baseball like a lot of
pitchers get this and i've been doing a
lot of martial arts over the past couple
of years more specifically like a lot of
sword training lightsaber a lot of like
that same like repetitive motion i have
basically beat my body up over the past
couple of years this is also something
that is completely i mean it's not a
topic that i want to get into a lot of
people have been coming after me and
saying that i deserve this because i got
the vaccine this is what i get this is
what i'm like i'm sorry what no matter
what your beliefs are i am not blaming
the vaccine but i'm also not denying
that maybe that could have something to
do with it because honestly we don't
have all of the answers but for those
who are curious and just want to really
get their little noses into all of my
medical history i did not end up getting
the booster shot because i had gotten
not i have actually not had coveted i
did have the two shots and then i didn't
get the booster because when i went to
get it over christmas i ended up getting
sick and then through january my sister
ended up getting covered so then i never
ended up getting the booster and then
now that this happened i'll be
definitely holding off for just a little
bit just because of the medications and
stuff that i'm currently on which i'm
now on blood thinners for the next three
to six months just to get rid of the
part of the blood clot actually broke
off in the hospital and went to my lung
and that's where things get very very
serious because it's very dangerous
because that can travel it can travel to
your heart it can travel to your brain
you can have a stroke and things happen
very quickly so i just wanted to get my
vaccine history out there so that people
can stop making up assumptions i didn't
even realize that this was a an issue
this thoracic outlet syndrome so my
entire life i've been very active in
sports i've always tried to
do like a lot of strength training and
lifting but it has been so difficult for
me i was just like maybe that's just
maybe i'm just weak and i need to work
out more but i have always struggled
with doing like overhead presses or
doing anything where my arms are held up
out to the side like they get i can't
even explain like the fatigue that i
feel and then my arms just like slowly
like kind of drain and they start
feeling like numb and this has happened
my entire life so this has not something
that is like a new occurrence but i
didn't know that there was a potential
reason and that reason could be purely
anatomical the way that a lot of people
are kind of structurally built their
ribs can be placed up too high or you
can even have a freaking extra rib and
then that presses on nerves on veins or
like kind of the muscle tissue and stuff
inside of here is all wound so tight
that it starts pressing on things that
it shouldn't so that's where the surgery
comes into play where they either oh my
god like they remove your extra rib or
they remove said first rib and there's
obviously a lot of you know
complications that can come with that
they could puncture your lung because
it's so close and it can do some sort of
like nerve damage and then that can also
ultimately lose
feeling or
then you can be left with chronic pain
in your arm i'm obviously one of the
people that i'm like okay i don't
obviously don't like hospitals i'm i've
never really been to them i'm always
very healthy so this was all kind of
like a very kind of scary sort of
experience but it also made a lot of
sense dating back to like why i've
always struggled with doing certain
types of workouts now a lot of people
that i also have talked to who have had
something similar have been diagnosed
previous to the vaccine i'm just giving
you guys my story and all of the people
that i've talked to have all had this
prior to the vaccine i'm not telling you
what to do or what you shouldn't do but
i'm just giving you my personal
experience what has happened with me and
how i'm gonna kind of now figure out
what to do with the rest of my life
because once you do have a blood clot
that can then
lead to others easily that can then lead
to others more easily and now that i
know kind of like the signs and symptoms
to watch out for and the different kinds
of activities that i have to be careful
doing i'm much more well informed but
the route that i think that i'm gonna
take for the next however long because
they basically gave me two
solutions it's like you're either gonna
be a blood thinners for the rest of your
life or you're gonna have to get your
ribs taken out i'm like oh god there's
gotta be something else so i did a
little searching did a little googling
you know as we all do which i mean you
can find a lot of good information a lot
of not good information but most of the
information that i found incredibly
helpful was from people who have reached
out to me personally who said hey i've
had this similar thing this is what i
did and this is what worked for me so i
also had someone reach out and
they worked with a physical therapist
and after doing a bunch of research as
well there are a lot of physical therapy
things that you can do if you have this
specific type of syndrome so i'm hoping
that physical therapy will work for me i
found a physical therapist i'm going to
start working with her and see how that
goes obviously if surgery is the route
that i'm going to have to go so that
i'll be able to get back to doing
lightsaber
training and doing martial arts again
then i will probably go that route
because i
miss it so much like i've i've
definitely not been in a very good state
over the past couple of weeks i'm saying
that i haven't been filming videos but
it was honestly just like my choice like
i literally just could not put on makeup
or come up here and like make videos but
like
me overall like my health right i feel
great like i actually feel better than i
did before i went in so it was kind of
like okay look this thing happened to
you take as much time as you need just
seeing you hi speaking to myself if you
want to freaking watch tv for two weeks
like go watch tv for two weeks because
that is something that like you don't
really get an opportunity to do very
often so
i was like all right i'm gonna i'm gonna
freaking just really fully recover i
don't know if i'm like fully recovering
or now i've just kind of like degressed
back into
um i don't know not feeling well because
i'm it's like a vicious cycle of like
man i'm just watching tv i should be out
doing something and then it's just like
you know i'm sure all of you guys have
kind of been in that sort of a situation
but all things considered i am doing
very well i just started kind of getting
back into a little workout plan i mean
the doctor when i left i was like yo do
you think i can like run he's like yeah
sure you'll be fine i'm gonna slowly
start getting back into
running i've been doing a lot of like
low impact kind of stuff i've been
trying to avoid doing any sort of arm
movements any type of like weightlifting
just because i haven't met with the
physical therapist yet so i kind of want
to like have a professional assess like
what do you think i can do what's the
best kind of way to tackle this other
than that like i feel great i've decided
to stop drinking caffeine and that kind
of stemmed from just not being able to
drink it in the hospital and this has
been a purely like a personal choice
this has nothing to do with medical like
no one has said that i should not drink
it but i can't even explain to you the
difference
in
how i feel like i have this sense of
calmness coffee i think is like really
was messing with me and i didn't even
realize it like every single day i would
have
just i was just anxious like my heart
would be pounding like i would get
worked up very easily about things like
if something was going wrong i would
just be like stressed and now
i mean for an example like my sister and
i recorded a podcast and then we forgot
to hit stop on the on the road caster
and she unplugged it and we lost all the
audio for the podcast after like filming
for two hours really recording this
podcast and i was just like well
you know that happened it's fine and
before i would have been feeling so
anxious and like stressed out and just
like thinking of like all these other
like scenarios of like well how do i fix
it i'm just like that happened i'll deal
with it when i have to deal with it and
i think that most of that calmness has
come from no caffeine and i don't think
there's ever been a time that i have
been off of caffeine like this long
because normally i would quit drinking
coffee for a couple of days but i would
still be drinking yerba mate which has
obviously caffeine in it as well but
i've been no caffeine for like oh my god
like 24 days now
the hospital the most pain that i was in
i think was the migraines that i was
getting from the lack of coffee and
caffeine that was more painful
than the actual like procedures and
stuff that was happening which was kind
of crazy and and kind of made me like
reassess is that something that i want
to be addicted to and i was like no i
don't and even before if i was traveling
like i would be packing yerba mate like
in my suitcase and i do miss it so much
but i think in the long run not having
that dependency and being reliant on
something i feel so free and i think
that freedom has kind of seeped sort of
into i don't know my new like
stress-free carefree kind of mode i
don't even know how to explain it like
i've never felt this way before like
maybe it's because i had a near-death
experience or maybe it's because i'm not
drinking caffeine or maybe it's both so
i definitely highly recommend if you are
feeling anxious and you drink a lot of
caffeine there's definitely a huge
correlation and i
this was like a couple years ago i
remember i think tyler and i were
filming and i just like started just
like we were about to shoot and i just
started like having a panic attack and
it wasn't like too aggressive or
anything and i was like we i can't film
anymore like we have to stop and we just
stopped filming and i just like went and
like laid down and i was just thinking
about like how much caffeine i was
drinking like i would drink a cup of
coffee in the morning then i'd have
another year of mate i'd have another
cup of coffee for lunch i'd have another
mate later i was like i'm overloading my
body i'm basically i'm poisoning it
essentially with with so much caffeine
and it's like my heart can't handle that
and just i was just i felt so weird so i
will say that um the only thing that i
did kind of fall off the boat on was i
was trying not to eat candy or a lot of
sugar but it was easter this past uh
this past week and easter candy is it's
it's my weakness like i was losing it i
was like oh my gosh easter candy like
peanut butter eggs and just like little
egg chocolates oh so
that i'm not proud of but at some point
i was like you know what i'm gonna
freaking enjoy this easter candy because
it is delicious so i guess that was just
kind of like a long sort of update of
kind of my personal well-being i mean
i'm feeling great i think the the one
thing is uh concerning is obviously like
we don't really have like
a set plan yet in action but the fact
that i'm still on the blood thinners is
also a little bit scary just because if
i do get cut or if i hit my head or if i
hit a part of my body i could
potentially bleed out could have
internal bleeding which is kind of a
scary thought to be kind of like walking
around in your daily life and just have
sort of this extra sort of i don't know
i need a bubble of protection around me
so i don't want to be on blood thinners
forever but all things considered like
i'm leading a perfectly normal life
right now i'm clearly not doing my
morning life fight training because
probably shouldn't be knife fighting on
uh blood thinners well i think the
doctors thought i was joking when i was
like so i shouldn't be doing any like
knife fighting or like any of that like
no no of course not i was like okay i
think they thought it was a joke but
little did they know it was very very
serious question i did ask if you guys
had any questions on twitter and so i
thought i would answer a couple of those
um jake is asking what games do i play
most during recovery i didn't play any
games i watched so much tv that it's
absolutely just
so crazy i have some uh press accounts
that allow me to watch some early access
to shows but i'm not gonna tell you what
because i don't even know if they're out
or announced but i've watched so much tv
not proud of it but i don't know i
really really enjoy it this one's kind
of interesting aaron is asking if i can
discuss my insurance situation and how
that relates to the care that i received
further as a creator can you elaborate
how when where is it easy to find good
plans and care so this is actually kind
of difficult because i don't really know
what all my insurance plan is going to
cover so i'm kind of finding that out as
we go i know i do have a pretty decent
plan since i pay like i think like five
to six hundred dollars a month for this
and i've been paying this for like ever
since i am self-employed i do have i
mean i think it's like a business kind
of insurance plan but i'm like the only
one on it i think there are different
tiers of plans but i think one of the
most important things that you can do is
have health insurance like if there's
something that you have to kind of
put aside and not purchase or
do without insurance is the most
important thing and i mean you can get
various ranges of coverage so i think
finding something that could be the
least expensive but at least it's
something because you have no idea i
mean i think my medical bills from that
stay is going to be i mean it's going to
be over a half a million dollars easily
because of all of the medication that i
was on i was in the icu for two nights i
mean that alone like is
just astronomical plus ambulance er like
all of those things are
very very very expensive and i think
that there's so much that needs to be
done with healthcare not just insurance
wise but healthcare in general i don't
know it's it's a mess over here and it's
it's scary but i'm so grateful like i
had such incredible nurses uh my sister
was there like every step of the way she
was like washing my hands and like
brushing my teeth and brushing my hair
because i couldn't move i was just i was
like in this position for like a three
day straight like could not move uh so
you definitely realize
what you can't do when you can't do
something and how much you missed that
like simple things like i just i
couldn't go to the bathroom like i had
to have assistance going to the bathroom
not a fun time at all but i guess
getting back to your insurance question
um i will keep you updated because i'm
also terrified because there are some
plans where i would have to pay 20
of the overall bill after it hits a
certain point which is like well let me
do the math actually i don't want to do
the math but
if my bill is like eight hundred
thousand dollars like i don't know
that's a lot don't i don't i can't i
don't i don't wanna think about it right
now until i
have to and so far the bills have
started trickling in so
evan is asking what is jpig so jpg
whether you like nfts whether you hate
them this is a project that i've been
working on and i've been hand drawing
every single one of these you guys can
follow it on twitter jpg and
um i'm basically going to try to do
everything in my power to make sure that
this is an nft drop that everyone who
hates nfts this is kind of like taking
that and spinning it so it's not
something that you will hate won't be a
cash grab i'm going to be doing it on an
environmentally friendly chain and it's
basically going to be kind of like an
extension of me i love pigs and they've
always been such an incredible animal
and i just love them so much so this is
going to be kind of something separate
from what i'm doing but it's also what
i'm doing i've always wanted to have a
really cool merch company there's been
so many things in the past that i
haven't done that is a pig themed um i
have basically i have like a full
children's book that i kind of wrote
many many years ago that i never ended
up releasing so i kind of want to have
that be a part of it there's incredible
merch ideas that i have and there's also
just the aspect of being able to be a
part of the community like the ijustine
community like this is where we're gonna
be like we're gonna be a part of the
jpeg like you can become a jpeg you can
be yourself but you can also be this
character so i'm like so excited about
it like i can't even explain and i know
there's so many scammy nft projects and
that's where it gets kind of interesting
because yeah it's like a lot of these
are scams they're just people that you
don't even know and they're just like
releasing these projects and people are
buying into the hype i don't even care
if this is hyped up like if you want it
do it if you don't don't but i want it
to be something that's accessible i
don't want it to be like this crazy out
of reach
project that my real true i just seen
fans who have been here from the
beginning like i need to find you guys
i have to find you and have a way to
connect with you so that i can get you a
pig so that's like my goal i'm trying to
figure it all out and it's definitely
not that easy but i have all of the art
done i drew every single thing in
procreate so just know that you get a
jpeg like i freaking drew it i drew all
of it it's been so fun i love it i'm so
so so excited about it but yeah i'm
still figuring all that out but if you
guys want to follow that definitely do
so and i'm going to find a way to try to
find all of the hardcore ij fans out
there and make sure they can get a pig
so if that's you just i'm i'm coming for
you
renee is asking if tim cook had a
lightsaber what color would that
lightsaber be i think it would be purple
because when we were talking about the
purple ipad he seemed super into it and
i feel like we're actually in that video
too he was behind the um the rainbow
little backdrop that was at apple so
maybe it could be like a rainbow
lightsaber that would be cool and
emily's asking will there be another
vlog university soon oh my gosh i've
just been discussing this because that
was such a fun time and also as a part
of jpeg like when you're a holder of one
of these nfts like you're gonna get
access to other things so it's like i
even envisioned that if you have a jpeg
that would get you early access to
getting tickets to vlog university this
would get you early access to like
basically anything that i'm doing
outside of like youtube so it's kind of
i'm just i'm so excited about it and it
even kind of is stemming from i went to
the nftla conference a couple weeks ago
and it was really really fun so it's
kind of cool to be there like as a
community member and not someone who was
actually presenting and it was really
kind of refreshing because i got to kind
of take a step back and sort of see what
the conference experience is like from
someone who's attending as opposed to
someone who was putting it on so i feel
like i learned a lot about that who
knows what's going to happen like
anything's possible but vlog university
was so
fun and i had so much fun meeting you
emily and so many other people who came
out it would be so funny if i didn't hit
record because if that if i didn't hit
record i'm just gonna go watch tv and
just say you're not getting a video okay
we're recording oh my god to say that
that hasn't happened before uh yeah i'd
be a liar because i've definitely
thought i was recording or audio was
recording and it wasn't so
that's the update
i honestly can't thank you guys enough
for being so supportive and just all of
your kind words and i mean everyone has
been just reaching out like it's it's
meant so much to me like i can't even
tell you like i couldn't even like use
my little fingers while i was in the
hospital so we didn't really tell very
many people while i was there because i
didn't want to be overwhelmed and just
exhausted by trying to read messages so
i kind of kept it to myself for at least
a week and then finally once i was out
had some answers that's what i made the
video but if you do want to go watch the
full video i'll put a link in the
description and you can go check that
out and i guess if anybody ever feels
not right like you think something is
wrong with your body like don't hesitate
go advocate for yourself if you think
that it might be nothing maybe it's
nothing but it could be something
definitely you should be on the safe
side and go get it checked out even if
it's just at some sort of urgent care or
something like that like don't even know
how time is of the essence like if i
would have waited a little bit longer i
may have died may have lost my arm so
just putting that in perspective of how
something that can go from zero to a
hundred real quick it can happen with
that i will see you guys in my next
video and i mean i might as well just
say hey if you haven't subscribed hit
the subscribe button hit the bell to be
notified when i post new videos which
now i feel like i feel like i'm back so
i'm pretty hyped about it kind of gave
myself that recovery time but i miss you
guys i miss creating i miss editing um
i'm gonna have to just not watch any
more tv for a while so
i will see you guys in the next one bye
[Music]